[Applause]  very delicate balance mouths will get  hit by a house suit so this could be big  damage if this heaven happened the  knight will go on scaling yes it can  break that  there's a punishment  you're going down yeah going up going  down  look at the damage oh my damn oh yes  let's see here he said life leads but  the regular  could potentially kill this there you go  is this going to kill  oh  millions  oh  big  damage  oh it's 60 50 right now who's gonna get  the hands  i like the fact that oh nice  while then four when the down four four  gets a float on the wall heaven to hell  the team mario's going  that's exactly how the game plan of  kazumi should be  though  uh  something further  and that okie has been really friendly  to vermillion  [Music]  [Applause]  oh  but electric is getting him closer to  that victim  with a full head of steam pretty pretty  scary  take it downstairs  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  you